ça c'est un aliment
ultra transformé
ça aussi et ces boissons là aussi
en smoothie d'un café ou en grand verre
le lait de sur cette animal et de plus
en plus remplacé par des boissons à base
de végétaux pour des raisons écologiques
ou des raisons de santé les ventes
augmentent annuellement de 33% depuis 5
ans
le lait d'avoine
amande des cachous pour mettre dans les
smoothies et le lait d'avoine c'est plus
pour les cafés même si André sont en
plein virage végétal avec l'aide de leur
nutritionniste ils ont fait des choix
ils ne consomment que des boissons
végétales
les boissons végétales il faut pas que
ça soit le centre de notre alimentation
une boisson végétale c'est pas la base
l'alimentation c'est pratique pour
remplacer le lait et les produits
laitiers dans notre alimentation
[Musique]
pratique peut-être mais santé voilà
qu'une étude sur près de 650 boissons
végétales a été menée par un imminent
chercheur de l'université de Washington
comme je suis beaucoup attiré par le
paradoxe ce que j'appelle le paradoxe
nutritionnel d'un côté ce sont des
boissons avec un certain entre les
nutritionnel et de l'autre côté c'est
sûr que ce sont des poissons
parce que voilà ces boissons ont été
classifiées par le système brésilien
Nova reconnu internationalement et
utilisé par des instances de santé
publique qui évaluent les aliments selon
leur degré de transformation oui oui
dans la même catégorie que les frites
hamburger ou friandise
faut ajouter des visionnaires de
concentré de protéines pour améliorer le
temps petit dans ces produits on ajoute
aussi du sucre des gras des gommes des
vitamines des agents de conservation et
des rehausseurs de goûts l'approche Nova
du moment que des additifs on classe ça
dans
ultra transformé mais on ne fait pas la
différence entre les additifs qui sont
inoffensifs et les additifs qui sont
dangereux si on avait mis du poly survêt
60 dans les boissons végétales là
j'aurais dit Oh attention est-ce qu'on
doit ajouter beaucoup de de nutriments
pour avoir l'équivalent en protéines ça
dépend quel choix on fait c'est sûr que
si on prend une boisson par exemple de
soya légumineuse c'est quand même très
complet comme aliment il y a beaucoup de
protéines il y a beaucoup de nutriments
il y a beaucoup de vitamines minéraux
oui c'est sûr qu'on a ajouté certaines
choses pour équivaloir en termes de
quantité calcium au lait de vache oui
c'est un produit végétal qui bénéficie
de l'euro actuellement de la science sur
les produits végétaux mais c'est un
produit ultra déformer souvent auquel on
ajoute beaucoup de sucre pour l'épidémie
biologiste Michel Lucas on en demande
beaucoup à un simple liquide on est dans
quelque chose qu'on appelle la
révolution industrielle ou les
technologies modernes où on a tendance
chez l'humain à tout mettre sous forme
liquide parce que ça va plus vite on
devrait peut-être manger la fourmi
initiale les légumineuses entières et
aucun problème les noix au contraire
entier ça se mange très très bien il
faut être réaliste aujourd'hui puis les
gens qui veulent éliminer les produits
laitiers il faut leur offrir une
alternative et si on prend une boisson
digitale de bonne qualité moi je pense
que c'est un aliment qui fait vraiment
partie d'une scène alimentation
des produits avec des listes
d'ingrédients parfois longues et parfois
très courte
faut bien choisir sa boisson végétale il
y a toute une gamme il y en a qui sont
très intéressantes d'autres beaucoup
moins évidemment on commence à en avoir
là casser d'imiter vraiment la texture
et le goût du lait là et souvent on
regarde les ingrédients puis c'est de
l'eau et de l'huile comme première
ingrédient donc ça c'est moins
intéressant l'aliment prend un rôle
deuxième de deuxième rang on le fait
passer au deuxième rang pour une
catégorie qui est beaucoup plus
importante qui est le nutriments ça
contient plus de protéines ça contient
certains minéraux ça contient certaines
vitamines mais finalement c'est plus un
aliment on nous fait croire que un faux
aliment un aliment sur transformé si on
y ajoute un petit peu de sens c'est
meilleur qu'un vrai aliment qu'on peut
masquer qu'on peut déguster qu'on peut
savourer Michel Lucas va même jusqu'à se
demander pourquoi tant de gens veulent
une boisson qui pour imiter le lait doit
être autant transformée le régime
végétal n'est pas la solution pour ce
chercheur c'est pas le modèle
alimentaire le plus santé
japonaise a très bien montré que le
véganisme était pas le régime supérieur
au niveau planétaire c'est pas le seul
il y a plein d'autres modèles
alimentaires c'est une mode aussi c'est
Laura finalement des produits végétaux
qui fait en sorte que les gens se
tournent vers ça il y a un offre de plus
en plus souvent à des fois moins cher et
le problème c'est que les gens goûtent
pas vraiment se produit là parce qu'on y
ajoute beaucoup de sucre si on prend une
boisson originale ben c'est l'équivalent
à peu près d'un sachet de sucre par
tasse
vanille 2 partage fraise 3 chocolats
c'est le grand gagnant 4 sachets de
sucre par tasse si on veut une boisson
au chocolat on peut la remonter soi-même
avec du cacao et des dattes
la couleur ressemble n'est-ce pas alors
je vais vous faire goûter à ça
nos experts s'entendent tout de même
pour dire qu'il y a des produits plus
intéressants que d'autres sur le marché
mon premier choix ce serait vraiment une
boisson de soya qui est enrichi et qui
est le plus possible sans sucre et qui
produit le plus localement possible
un produit végétal comme cela que ce
soit le soya que ce soit évidemment un
peu moins parce que ça vient de très
loin et ici on n'a pas d'émulsifiant on
n'a pas trop de sucre je pense que c'est
une bonne alternative aux produits
laitiers pour les gens qui en veulent
pas ou qui peuvent simplement une façon
aussi d'éviter les additifs c'est de les
faire maison et c'est pas trop compliqué
on met juste de l'eau du chanvre on
l'aromatise un peu et en soi ça va faire
un lait jusqu'à maintenant ça a pas
l'air tellement pétissant comme ça mais
une fois brassé vous allez voir si
intéressant
mais on peut mettre un peu plus de on
peut mettre un petit peu plus de vanille
à ce moment-là
c'est bien de l'autre côté il y a quand
même des produits à base de plantes qui
sont pas mauvais du tout non plus c'est
le choix pour les consommateurs
[Musique]